the jurogan experience
legends of tattooing he's one of the
biggest
yeah we did one seat and
that was painful
that kicked my ass
is the back more painful than the arms
oh yeah really the arms are
easy yeah the arms are pretty easy i
basically
you feel it but you're not
crying on my back you're crying there
was not crying but about to there were
points that my arm were shaking really
without me moving it
wow see that's it's weird what parts
hurt because um
uh the elbow hurts a lot like the inside
of the elbow that [ __ ] hurts a lot i was
like i thought that was numb because
like you think about how many times you
hit things with your elbows it doesn't
hurt at all i crack heads with elbows
but the
the little ink it will make you pay it's
crazy it's weird yeah i have my full leg
a dragon yeah like top to bottom my leg
that's also awful really leg is awful
like some parts like some parts in the
tide where the sun don't goes
um the sun doesn't go
you know
you know what's fun about my my leg
tattoo when this guy was to do my inner
tie
he was pushing
my balls aside
so he can ink right and i was like he's
touching your balls
kind of he was pushing him away well
he's touching him a little bit
this is you know what's the crazy part
when i was there i was just like
because normally i get tattoo right
after fight because that's my rest time
and i was just thinking
this is painful this is awkward
i was usually thinking about like what's
worse the guy pushing my dick away or
the pain right there because it was so
painful that i was like
wow i'm hurting well the guy pushing
your dick away is just weird no but
that's not painful right he's not
painful but he's very weird
he's painful in a way you know whatever
it's weird it feels good you're like
damn this is enjoyable yeah easy to say
like
[Music]
you don't want that that would be a
problem or maybe you do maybe you do no
it doesn't happen not for you but for
some people happens yeah but i was like
that
it was painful and awkward that was hard
that was it was hard to i was just like
please finish that part quick
so who did your leg uh this guy called
mark nava yeah he's uh he's really good
in japanese style and he's like a mile
from my house
in costa mesa oh well costa mesa that
whole los angeles system that whole
southern california area is amazing for
tattoos yeah we are and i've been lucky
most of my tattoos you know some people
got some tattoos that they're like they
just get it because they wanted to
they're [ __ ] yeah i'm lucky every even
what everything i got in ecuador it's
it's just clean
and it's all what it won how much of it
did you get in ecuador
i get
basically all this arm mark nava did
just the snake
and the spider in the back
then the rest is all in headquarter
all these armies in ecuador besides the
hand
this is sean topper another good guy in
in around in costa mesa area
then my back mr cartoon
having a back piece like your back piece
um we just filmed it we just took a
video before the podcast but missed a
cartoon
legend
of all my tattoos
that's
that's number that's number one has to
be how was it to get in with him
well every time he he he's easily kind
of like he works with with ruka with the
brand oh okay so he comes busy but all
the time
so every time he comes around i'm like
come on dude
come on dude get me and he's like he's
pretty chill you know
and and yeah he's pretty cool and then
he's like okay talk to my assistant
and i used to rush the [ __ ] out of this
guy i'm like yo get me in
and basically he wasn't tattooing during
the pandemic he wasn't doing nothing
really and that was his first tattoo
back oh wow so so he's just chilling
he's just chilling wow i guess he can
chill at this point right oh yeah he's a
bad [ __ ] he's a bad [ __ ]
he don't need to take two more people no
so i'm glad he tattooed me it's amazing
that he did yeah when you get a guy like
that man god that's a he's just a legend
he's a legend yeah and i'm gonna keep
finishing my back because i got spots in
the sides i'm gonna finish with him did
you do it at his studio
yeah in santa monica does he have
pictures on his walls of all the people
that he's tattooed dude when i was there
i was tripping just like eminem in one
side then all the art they have
they have like a barber shop that he
owns next like literally next door and
the the seats are like from the 80s like
original
paint by him i was like wow this guy's
tattooing me wow so when i get to the
shop he's like you want to smoke i'm
like [ __ ] yeah
he gives me a joint of this i know what
he's smoking and i was like bro this is
a strong it's pure gossiping brother
a beer castle when when he started
tattooing me i was just like
i was way too high ah i was way too
sensitive when you're high right do you
feel it more oh i was that's why i was
freaking out yeah when i'm
drinking though drinking you know barely
feel [ __ ] i never drink drink tattoo
really ever
i have i might start doing that now yeah
it's a good move because it dulls the
pain quite a bit i definitely smoke all
the time i got it to two and that's not
that would hurt oh it hurts more yeah
because you're like you're super
sensitive you're sensitive and then
you're like
you feel your hurry going up yeah
the pain hurts and then because
sometimes with absorber my heart goes
high because your body's going through
some [ __ ] yeah
your body's also like hey [ __ ] run away
from this pain why are you sitting still
when they
when i did when i get my neck done that
was when i was like i need to get the
[ __ ] out of here how is the neck the
most painful the throat is pretty [ __ ]
up every time you swallow good luck
yeah right and they're getting in there
and then my head was
falling from the [ __ ] table oh
because you have to lean back yeah right
oh my goodness yeah so i was like i
won't do my neck anymore thank god it's
done neck pain is weird pain because
like your body's like this is a bad
place to have pain like you shouldn't
have anything
around here this is vulnerable as [ __ ] i
know
when he saw my first tattoo
you [ __ ] idiot sean shelby said that
yeah he's like you won't be able to get
a job i'm like i don't need a job you
give me a job
i was like you give me a job he was mo
he was motivating me to don't be an
idiot i was like hey i'm gonna be in the
uc for a long time that's such a silly
thing to say sean shelby you silly goose
we were laughing about it after the
frankie fight he told me like hey
you're good i'm like i told you i'm an
idiot but i told you that's so silly he
was laughing about it